وفي سوريا المجاوره ارتفع العدد الاجمالي
لقتل الزلزال في جميع انحاء البلاد الى
نحو
4500 قتيل واكثر من
7300 مصاب وقدر مكتب الامم المتحده للشؤون
الانسانيه عدد المتضررين في الزلزال بما
لا يقل عن سته ملايين شخص
وذكر مصدر اممي بمحدوديه الامكانات من
معدات ووقود وغيرهما وقال ان ذلك يعرقل
جهود الانقاذ والاسعاف
اكد نائب مدير الدفاع المدني السوريه منير
مصطفى للجزيره انه لم تصل حتى الان اي
معدات انقاذ او اليات خاصه لانتشال
العالقين لا من الامم المتحده ولا من
غيرها الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا التي
تسيطر عليها المعارضه وانتقد نائب مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري ما سماها التقصيره
والتاخير في ارسال المساعدات الى
المنكوبين في مناطق الشمال السوري
يبقى معنا من سرمدا في رفاق ادلب السيد
منير مصطفى نائب مدير الدفاع المدني
السوري سيد منير هذه المناشدات التي
اطلقتموها والتي يعني استمعنا الى بعضها
على مر الايام هل لقيت اي اذنا صاغيه الى
حد الان
نعم للاسف يعني لم تلقى اذان صاغيه حتى
الان لم يصل اي معدات حقيقيه او فرق انقاذ
حقيقيه الى شمال غرب سوريا طبعا للاسف نحن
وصلنا شرفنا على انتهاء اليوم السادس من
من وقوع هذه الكارثه والحقيقه يعني الامل
بالعثور على احياء تحت الانقاض في الابنيه
المدمره شمال غرب سوريا بات معدوما لن
اقول ضعيفا بل باتا وصل الى مرحله المعدوم
وفرق الانقاذ والدفاع المدني الفوز
البيضاء اعلنت انها انتقلت من مرحله سحب
العالقين من تحت الانقاض الى مرحله انتشال
الجثث من تحت الالقاب طبعا هذه المعدات
ستكون هي العمليه سيد منير
في الحقيقه هذه العمليه يتم في هذه الحاله
استخدام بعض الاليات الكبيره من بوادر
وتراكس واليات روافع هي تستخدم لرفع
الصبات البيتونيه الكبيره طبعا هنا عندما
تكون قد تاكدنا بان الموجود هو تحت
الانقاذ هو جثه يتم التعامل مع الصبات
البترونيه بالادوات الهندسيه التي تكون هي
مخصصه لهذا الشيء حقيقه يعني هنا يكون سحب
الجثث يكون اسهل بهذه الطريقه عندما يكون
التعامل مع مصاب وهو على قيد الحياه يكون
هناك حذر شديد لكي لا تزيد الاصابه كي لا
يكون هناك تاخير في الوصول الى هذا المصاب
وسحبه من تحت الالقاب طبعا نحن
منذ بدات هذه الكارثه ناشدنا ويعني صحنا
بصحنا باعلى صوتنا حتى يصل الصوت الى كل
دول العالم لان الساعات الاولى هي ساعات
ذهبيه هلا الفارغ البسيط
الذي يعني هو بين المباني الموجوده في
شمال غرب سوريا والمباني الموجوده ضمن
تركيا يعني هناك سؤال قد يتبادر الى الذهن
كيف حتى الان يتم اخراج ناجين في تركيا
ولا يتم ولم يبقى ناجين في شمال غربي
سوريا طبعا الجواب بسيط
الابنيه المتواجده في في تركيا هي بالغالب
هي ابنيه مصممه من اجل مقاومه الزلازل
فيكون طريقه الانهيار هي طريقه الميول او
انهيار جزئي بطوابق معينه يعني قلما يكون
هناك انهيار كلي فهذه انهيارات تخلف فتحات
نحن نسميها مثلث الحياه داخل داخل هذه
الانهيارات وهذه الفراغات داخل الانقاذ
تكون كفيله في الحفاظ على ارواح الاشخاص
لفتره اطول من الاشخاص الذين يكونوا قد
تعرضوا الى اصابه وهم تحت الانقاض حتى
يعني هذه الفتحات الموجوده داخل الانقاذ
يعني تكون كثيره للحفاظ على حياه الشخص من
الى سته ايام بالحد الاعظمي هو حقيقه هي
اربع ايام هي الايام المعروفه التي يكون
هناك يعني احتمال بسيط ان يبقى هؤلاء
الاشخاص احياء الا اذا كان هناك معجزات
وتكون الحياه اطول طبعا هناك اسباب كثيره
يعني لا يسع الوقت لذكرها يتعلق بالعمر
يتعلق في مكان التواجد يتعلق بموضوع هل هو
في حاله غيبوبه ام هو بوعيه من اجل موضوع
يعني فقدان السوائل من الجسم هناك تفاصيل
كثيره يعني تساهم في الحفاظ على حياه بعض
الاشخاص لفترات اطول من الفتره الطبيعيه
المعتاده اما الابنيه في في سوريا الحقيقه
في شمال غرب سوريا هي ابنيه يعني في
غالبها نشات في فتره الحرب فكانت ليست لها
كل مقومات الامان الحقيقيه التي يجب ان
تتواجد في هذه الابنيه فهي غير مهيئه
لمقاومه هذه الزلازل فتكون انطباق هذه
الابنيه بطريقه اصعب بكثير من الابنيه
المقاومه فهي تنطبق يعني بتعبير يعني
يستعملهم بشكل سندويش بانل يعني الصبات
البريطانيه تكون منطبقه بشكل كامل فوق
بعضها بحيث لا تخلف ورائها الا القليل من
مثلثات الحياه او الغرف الضيقه التي قد
تكون تحوي داخلها بعض الناس على قيد
الحياه شكرا لك سيد منير مصطفى نائب مدير
الدفاع المدني السوري